a principle that that one has to learn
early on here is that your you're going
to learn constantly but in terms of the
big picture success in individual
programs you can experience a lot more
failure than you are success and you you
have to accept that as a price of doing
business I think we have ourselves
focused very very specifically on trying
to reduce the frequency of failure or
increase the frequency of success but we
know that we're still going to fail more
often than we succeed but I think the
the fact that discovering and being part
of the discovery process for a new
life-saving therapy is such a rare
accomplishment among all of the
activities that human beings can
participate in that it's incredibly
compelling and it's motivating so you
have this opportunity to both learn and
once or twice in your career do
something absolutely remarkable in terms
of changing the situation for patients